last night the Durham report was
released and it basically confirms what
most of us knew that there was a soft
coup staged against the Trump
Administration first to stop him from
winning then to stop him from actually
being president this wasn't three days
of chaos it was three years intended to
disrupt the presidential Administration
in this country it was so damning this
report that even CNN came out and Jake
Tapper is like it essentially it almost
exonerates Trump like all my like it
literally does the report says that
there was no evidence no corroboration
and the FBI was pursuing this anyway
this is in my opinion criminal now of
course the argument from the FBI is
there's no evidence of anything criminal
but I think that's letting them off the
hook lightly because it's all about
criminal interpretation so I definitely
want to get into greater detail as we go
into the Durham report's findings but I
do want to point out even CNN saying
like this looks bad and that's bad
because CNN doesn't want to do it here's
a funny thing though Newsmax is now
beating CNN in the writings so yeah
sorry CNN you're out we got more news
however Bud Light is going to be
changing their cans they're freaking out
their sales are getting worse down 27.7
percent so uh a lot of good news a lot
of good news a lot of crazy news and uh
I want to I want to talk about Patriot
front because Joe Rogan on his show was
basically like those guys are feds no
question and my favorite point someone
made was that you know Patriot front is
feds because not a single person in the
group is OB
and they're like everybody knows that
when you see a bunch of like right-wing
Patriot dudes with guns and armor
they're overweight and so right yes
Sheamus he can't help himself that's
actually really funny but it's it's a
fair point like these guys are all fit
they're wearing khakis and Boots so
we'll get into all that but before we do
my friends head over to castbrew.com and
I have news this show is sponsored by us
our own coffee brand and we have now in
stock only a few hundred bags of rise
with Roberto Jr in fact I think it may
only be about 100 bags of rise with
Roberto Jr we are trying as hard as
possible to get this back in stock to
the point where we can keep up with the
demand but I know you all love our
rooster Roberto Jr so much you've bought
this coffee out we oversold we put in a
new order to roast some more it's sold
immediately with like a hundred bags
left so get it while you can with every
bag of rise with Roberto Jr with every
purchase you get a picture of Roberto Jr
on the back and we're actually going to
launching Collector's Editions with
unique pictures of Roberto Jr that you
can collect so that'll be coming soon
the simple version of the real ad is
we're launching our own companies
because we want to stand up for the
American values that we believe in that
you believe and we want to make
companies that won't back down we want
to sponsor ourselves we want to build
the parallel economy and this is Phase
One the purpose of cast brew coffee is
that we can set up coffee shops all over
this country to create cultural hubs
where people can have a cup of coffee
they'll see a TV screen on the wall and
what's on that TV screen it's going to
be crowded it's going to be Tim cast IRL
it's going to be Viva and Barnes it's
going to be people that you know and
trust instead of CNN and MSNBC and other
garbage and even Fox News then when some
random person walks in that coffee shop
saying I just want a cup of coffee up on
the TV they're going to be here in
Stephen Crowder they're going to be
hearing us that's how we build cultural
hubs throughout the city so go to
casper.com support us if you'd like but
you can also go to timcast.com
click join us in the menu bar become a
member to support us directly if you
like the work we do and if you sign up
at the 10 level for six months or the 25
level you will instantly get access to
submitting questions to call into the
uncensored members only show that goes
up Monday through Thursday at 10 10 pm
we will have one of those up for you
tonight so sign up today if you would
like to submit some questions smash the
like button subscribe to this Channel on
YouTube Share the show if you like it
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Natalie Winters hi
thank you so much for having me I'm so
excited to be here with you guys thanks
for being here who are you what are you
doing so I am the co-host and executive
editor of Steve bannon's War Room used
to be and still sort of am an
investigative reporter primarily
focusing on Chinese Communist Party
infiltration which of course dovetails
with the origins of kovid did a lot of
reporting on Hunter Biden's hard drive I
like to kind of footnote a lot of the
statements that people make about really
the amazing extent to which the Chinese
Communist party uh Curry's influence
favor in the United States right on well
thanks for joining us it should be fun
we got Sheamus got Seamus over here my
name is Seamus goggle and I was laughing
throughout the whole intro I'm sorry
dude that's hysterical that's such a
good point that's such a good point but
I have a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes where we upload cartoons we're
going to have one on Thursday that I
think you all are gonna enjoy a whole
lot and if you want you can become a
member at freedomtunes.com to support my
work pretty based cool and I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com
and I am back today uh Kellen is stopped
bullying me so I'm on the air I also
have some news I see that someone super
chatted saying they want official Tim
pool beanies we actually do now have a
large supply of official Tim cast
beanies however we decided we're not
going to be selling them we're only
going to be giving them out to select
members on a certain case-by-case basis
we're going right now I think we'll be
sending all of our Elite members these
uh these unique Tim cassopinis that we
have it says Tim cast on it's got a
picture of a little gorilla wearing uh
headphones and uh the reason is I don't
know if we're equipped to do actual
large-scale merchandising just yet so
for the time being we do have them and
we want to send them to members starting
with Elite members and then probably uh
somehow just basically sending these
people as a thank you and then try and
figure out how we can make them special
limited edition because we only have I
think like 200 or something like that
that's why it's like we can't just sound
because they'll be gone instantly and we
want to make them special so that you
can only get them in certain ways so
take a look uh look out for that if
you're in the uh Elite uh if you're an
Elite member but let's jump into this
first story we have this from
humanevents.com Durham report reveals
FBI Democrats staged soft coup of trump
Administration by Lemmy Emmett Libby
Evans and I would like to stress I
believe this is newsguard certified
human events that means it is true facts
information the Durham report begun in
May 2019 was intended to investigate
allegations that President Trump had
engaged in collusion collusion with
Russia to alter the 2016 presidential
election but it would have found instead
was an effort to undermine Trump's
presidency the confidence of the
American people and his administration
and to fuel media and Democrat
resentment and hatred for the man they
would sooner have shot on Fifth Avenue
then seen take the White House that's
some pretty good writing Libby they say
quote
our investigators determined that the
crossfire hurricane investigators did
not and could not corroborate any of the
substantive allegations contained in the
steel reporting not not was still able
to nor was still able to produce
corroboration for any of the reported
allegations even after being offered one
million or more by the FBI for such
corroboration the report reads later it
goes further to say that the information
was known to be rumor and speculation
Democrats planted fake evidence and then
used it against Trump in order to
justify their assumptions about his
guilt the FBI used that for probable
cause to further an investigation
without any basis at all within days of
their receipt the report reads the
unvetted and unverified steel reports
were used to support probable cause in
the FBI's fisa applications targeting
page a U.S citizen who for a period of
time had been an adviser to Trump as
discussed later in the report this was
done at a time when the FBI knew that
the same information Steeler provided to
the FBI had also been fed to the media
and others in Washington DC DC I'd like
to give you a simplified version so you
can understand what's going on the FBI
says no criminal culpability for a lot
of these people I think they're saying
like you know Hillary Clinton nothing
was overtly Criminal
here's how I see it imagine one day a
guy is uh walking past a bank carrying a
burlap sack and he walks up to the bank
steps drops the bag and walks away did
he commit a crime of course not he just
threw a burlap sack on the stairs of a
bank another guy walking into the bank
to cash a paycheck sees the burlap sack
and says oh somebody must have uh
accidentally left it outside picks it up
carries it inside throws it on the
ground in front of the counter catches
chicken leaves another guy crumples up a
note walking past the bank and throws it
through an open window you get where I'm
going with this one by one each of these
individuals did a small thing no single
person walked into that bank demanded
money filled a bag full of cash and fled
but each of these individuals did one
thing that if you were to analyze in and
of itself was not criminal but all
together
after all this goes down the bank teller
did fill the burlap sack with money and
then somebody did carry it outside then
someone else put it in the back of a
truck then someone else drove that truck
away and when the FBI comes and
interviews all of these individuals
they'll say look I don't know any of
these guys this was just in the public
and I stumbled upon it and the money was
taken from the bank and driven to a
secret hideout what happened with with
the the uh Trump Russia collusion was
that Democrats who wanted Trump
destroyed members of the media who
wanted Trump destroyed all claimed they
used publicly available information
to destroy Donald Trump's presidency
from the FBI claiming it was in the
media so we had to look into it but the
story in the media came from speculation
from people in the FBI it was one big
circular scheme and I think the only
reason Durham saying it's not criminal
is because he's going easy on these
people criminal indictments are
interpretable and I think anybody
looking at what these people did could
say if Adam Schiff goes on TV and he did
and says he has more than some more than
circumstantial evidence proving this
then there should be some kind of
criminal referral and we should not sit
back and allow all of these people to
destroy a presidency because I'll tell
you where we're at right now if nothing
comes of this if the extent of the
dermaport is yes they all did something
bad but it wasn't Criminal then there's
no country anymore because what's to
stop any political party from doing the
exact same thing to make sure no other
person can have a presidential
Administration again yeah exactly so if
nobody here broke the law that is an
indictment of our laws as they currently
stand so just to go over some of the
points that were made in the Durham
report
significant Reliance on investigating
leads that were funded by Trump's
opposition occurred uh they did not and
could not corroborate any of the
substantive allegations made by the
steel report the investigation was not
properly opened information was not
properly vetted it was carried out in an
improper manner FBI officials according
to the Durham report had a
predisposition to have a bias against
President Trump they didn't do their
basic due diligence and the FBI warned
the Clinton campaign of potential
Russian interference during the 2016
election but did not warn the Trump
campaign so people can say well in the
Durham report there isn't any statement
explicitly saying that there was an
attempt at a deep State coup he's just
saying that basically everyone who
handled this investigation was behaving
improperly because of their bias against
a sitting president well that's just the
distinction without a difference I don't
care if they all met in a cigar room and
rubbed their hands together and laughed
about the fact that they were trying to
subvert the US's democracy and the fact
that we had a democratic election and
people chosen out Outsider the fact is
what they were doing is functionally
identical they were trying to use bad
evidence to attempt to remove somebody
from Office who hadn't committed a crime
I think to me the most startling aspect
of this whole story is that the Durham
report at this Russia hoax that really
was just the opening Salvo of the deep
State's attempt to really nullify the
Trump presidency so I think it's
interesting if you sort of analyze the
Trump term through this Paradigm what I
mean by that the first impeachment
attempt the second impeachment attempt
the fact that the people who were
running you know PPO the presidential
personnel office the equivalent of HR in
the white house where a bunch of bush
Romney types were very establishment
Republicans so while it's important to
focus on the Russia hoax angle of it I
think it also shows you the extent to
which they were willing to go to to
thwart the Trump presidency before he
even became president right while he was
still a candidate so you can only
imagine how much they ratcheted up those
efforts to go after Trump once he
actually assumed off office and assumed
all the The Leverage the power that
comes with being president so I think
it's just it's such an interesting kind
of Paradigm to view all of the ways that
the Deep State really did go after Trump
I mean I think it continues yeah exactly
facing so many different types of
lawsuits and investigations it's hard to
count them all what's a seditious
conspiracy Sheamus do you know well I
would say just based on the words it's
people conspiring to oppose legitimately
elected authorities so if like I don't
know a group of people had a plan to say
like disrupt a presidential
Administration something like that I
mean over the period of three years
before his election is that seditious
I'll I'm just gonna I'm not gonna mince
words here
they convicted proud boys of seditious
conspiracy why because they were at a
protest Riot on January 6th that's it a
one day thing the left has done the same
thing except instead of laundering their
talking points through groups right like
the right does say the proud boys or the
Patriot front all these different
federally incited groups they just do
and I think sort of more high brow more
High classes through ngos this was three
years of the FBI and Democrats and the
media all working together to stop a
presidential Administration that is the
biggest conspiracy this country has ever
seen and the only thing the only is only
one thing that they're claiming make
that makes it not a conspiracy is it was
all an accident that's right every lie
from Schiff Every Lie from the media
every action taken by the FBI all coming
together to create a massive Russia
collusion collusion investigation with
Pulitzer prizes whoops all of the
reporters all of the Democrats and all
of the feds slipped on a banana peel at
the exact same time did a backflip
landed perfectly and won awards for it
and it was just one big accident and are
there were Awards gonna be withdrawn I
mean this is what bothers me the most I
know it's important to confirm to
Revelations that uh the Durham report
produces but nothing's gonna happen
right the proud boys are gonna have to
go back to court to argue that the text
messages where there are saying where
should we meet up on January 6 prove
that they didn't have a plan for that
day meanwhile no one involved in this is
going to face uh conspiracy charges and
I hate uh to turn this into grimcast but
it really is incredibly frustrating and
disheartening there is no punishment for
what happened there can be when Trump
gets reelected I expect him to to have
an AG
start issuing these indictments start
convening grand juries and grand juries
they say can can indeed a ham sandwich
Bring It On present the evidence and say
did these people conspire you know what
I'll tell you this Tit for Tat let's
play Tit for Tat if you're gonna accuse
Donald Trump of working for the Soviet
Union then we're gonna accuse you of
conspiracy because y'all did say these
things let's just go ahead and assume
you did it on purpose yeah well remember
Tim what they're going to try to argue
is that you're an insane conspiracy
theorist for thinking that basically
every relevant person within the Deep
State being tilted against Trump and
trying to unseed him on bad evidence
isn't an actual core is an actual coup
I'm sorry that's a bridge too far but
them believing that the president of the
United States literally colluded with
Russia to rig the election and he was an
asset of Putin the entire time is just
reasonable thinking and without any
evidence they could say that on National
Television to the American people well
let's slow down a second Sheamus do you
think the Democrats did what we know
they did you know it's a tough one man I
I gotta be honest yes or no thank you
yes or no I'm going to speak with my
lawyer yeah of course conspiracy theory
ah I got you and by the way I just have
to say I said you know a lot of my early
career had to do with focusing on
Chinese Communist Party infiltration if
Donald Trump's cardinal sin was you know
collaborating with the Russian
government which we know never happened
I mean the people who are accusing him
of doing that that is like textbook
projection in the sense that all of
these I I actually used to do this this
can tell you what kind of social life I
have but if you used to look at the
headlines that they would write on CNN
the New York Times Washington post about
Trump and linking him to Russia you
could basically cross out Trump and
replace it often with Democrats
sometimes establishment Republicans
Russia and put in China because the
connections exist so this whole idea
that there's this you know collaborating
inclusion with foreign governments and
like Democrats you guys wrote that
Playbook when you started taking cash
from Chinese Communist party influence
groups exactly and so we see how much
the goal post has moved over the years
right back in 2016 Donald Trump colluded
with the Russians we know he colluded
with the Russians the entire thing is a
bars the president is owned by the
Kremlin and then okay well well maybe he
colluded with them and then okay so well
there's no evidence that he colluded
with them but the investigation was done
in good faith and now it's okay well the
investigation wasn't done in good faith
and there were a lot of biases in it and
the FBI clearly played favorites by
warning the Clinton pick campaign not
the Trump campaign and they launched the
investigation on bad information but but
it wasn't too it was not an intentional
coup it's like okay I'm sure you know
every single thing you have said along
the way since this investigation first
began since this Russia gate farce was
incepted has been completely wrong and
now you expect us to believe you when
you say this wasn't a coup I'm sorry
we've run out of good faith the lawyer
involved in the first impeachment
tweeted out when Trump right before his
inauguration we are going to impeach you
yep like they expressed their intent
before there was any criminal
accusations or any any potential
wrongdoing or anything they could accuse
him of they said we will do it no matter
what and meanwhile in the same exact
time frame the FBI the treasury
Department was getting suspicious
activity report after suspicious
activity report based off the business
dealings of Hunter Biden and all you
know dozen Biden family members and they
were actively suppressing that these are
obviously politically exposed personnels
peps so they knew what Hunter Biden was
doing from the financial transactions
and it just shows you it's not even a
double standard of Justice because that
implies that we're in the same realm of
Standards it's it's otherworldly it's
it's just ridiculous yep and I think
that there's a lot to what you're saying
Hannah Claire about the fact that our
institutions probably will not punish
themselves for their wrongdoings I also
hear what you're saying Tim about the
fact that Trump being re-elected could
mean that he actually would go after
these people and they would be duly
punished for their crimes against this
nation
but I will say one thing
I believe that the real black pill is
that is not that you know people who
have
information that could lead to the
arrest of Hillary Clinton die it's that
no amount of information will ever lead
to the arrest of Hillary Clinton right
uh and that applies overall to this deep
state that maybe Trump does get in maybe
he is able to appoint investigators it's
certainly going to be an uphill battle
man we should have titled today's
episode
Tim cast reveals information that will
lead to the arrest it's like see what
happens you know uh maybe it will maybe
it will yeah maybe when uh Trump gets
back in office he will finally follow
through with locking up Hillary Clinton
because uh
I mean this was it it was the Democrats
it was the clintons it was Obama they
were trying to intentionally smear
Donald Trump to win an election and they
framed him as a traitor to this country
yeah and the headlines are going to be
Donald Trump uses justice system for his
own vindictive means to an end you know
what I mean I mean even if we were to
get some of these official Behind Bars
to have to uh
publicly face what they have done to the
American people not just Donald Trump
but to the people who supported him
right
there is no way that the media lets this
go right even now I mean I think part of
this time exactly what you're saying the
timeline you lied out of being like
there definitely was a problem all the
way to like well there wasn't anything
and also we are biased and we're sort of
admitting it by now they're gonna be
like well but he just got found guilty
in this case and he's being investigated
over here and let's talk to Alvin Bragg
and it almost doesn't matter because
they were just waiting to come up with
something else to try and hold against
Trump and it is honestly astounding I
don't know that we'll ever see anything
like it in our lifetime of someone they
hate more than Donald Trump I mean it's
truly unbelievable like that mainstream
media and the Deep state will go to
fight against him well I will say I
think there is someone or more
accurately a group they hate more than
Donald Trump and that's the American
people and they see Donald Trump as a
representative for the actual interests
of the American people and that bothers
them because they're used to seeing
politicians who are only interested in
representing the elite and so while it
may be the case that none of these
people face any actual punishment at any
of these media establishments or
anywhere in the Deep state with respect
to public opinion and people waking up
to their nonsense the one thing I can
say is the walls are closing in I'm just
imagining like high profile Democrat
fundraisers holding auditions to recruit
actors to play Democrats and they're
doing the interview and they're like all
right give me populist and they got like
AOC and she's saying like I think we
should text the rich like this is really
great you're really good now if you take
this job we have to warn you you will
have to shake hands and touch these
people and then she shutters oh I think
I can do it all right you got the job
we'll uh we'll we'll get you elected and
then you can be a Democrat and that's
that's how I view that's how I view all
the Democrats and the Republicans and be
completely honest except for like five
people
they're just they just despise and are
disgusted by Americans yes no well
that's exactly what it is right it's
it's funny so there's this idea of
loving the The Sinner and hating the sin
you know the Democrats they they like
love poverty and hate the poor they
really do they have this entire idea in
their heads that they're these champions
for the working class and they hate
everything that the working class stands
for and they'll even claim that it's
funny it applies other things like they
really they like love immigration and
they hate the Immigrant when you talk to
people who come here from Mexico about
their values and like how they feel
about gay marriage and abortion the left
is disgusted by it they hate everything
they stand for yeah I mean all of the
counties along the border in Texas where
there are levels of immigration
are red right they are populated by
people whose families have migrated from
Mexico they have conservative values but
you you see that theory play out too I
think even with the Russia hoax because
I also never sort of bought what they
were pushing right it's like oh because
a random Facebook account that was
somewhat linked to Russia shared an
article that was attacking Hillary
Clinton on false terms just because some
random Americans read it that now
influenced their vote they're now voting
for Donald Trump and I think you know if
you unpack that whole narrative that
they were pushing it really shows you
how dumb they think the American people
are right and how really influenceable
and just
because you read an article now you your
entire conviction the reason why you
support trump it can't be because you
actually support his policies on trade
and you want to take this country back
and you despise Hillary Hillary Clinton
to your core it's because you read an
article about Hillary Clinton actually
being you know related to who knows it's
actually absolutely
ludicrous conspiracy theorizing what
they argued was that
non-government Russian actors spending
46 000 worth of money on Facebook ads
that weren't even all targeted towards
one specific party
was an act of War we had actual elected
leaders saying that that was an act of
war from Russia interfering in our
election this is how delusional these
people are the best part too is if you
look I remember there was a press
release that Twitter had put out
probably like two years ago they were
talking about what they were doing to
mitigate foreign influence and they had
ranked all the different numbers of bots
that they had from different countries
and overwhelmingly I think it was by
like a 10 increase or rather uh like
Chasm between Bots from China and Russia
the Chinese Communist party influence on
Twitter dwarfed that of Russia so it's
so funny if you want to play with this
foreign influence narrative it's like
sure I'll take you your word on that
even though I don't believe you the
American people are smart enough to be
immune to that uh even if you want to
take them at their word the Chinese
Communist Party their influence still
prevails over Russia so it's just
bizarre Tick Tock yeah taking over right
so uh let me jump to this story we have
this tweet from Benny Johnson Elon Musk
calls us impression of the hunter Biden
laptop story election interference quote
some of these conspiracy theories have
turned out to be true I want to play
this clip for you I just want to stress
this one point as we're talking about
the Durham report and the interference
in our election and Trump's presidency
from 2016 till 2020 we also get to talk
about the second election interference
of intelligence agencies when they
sought to suppress and did suppress the
hunter Biden laptop story here is Elon
Musk giving an interview on the matter
patient of this I mean
um you know you do some tweets that seem
to be or at least give support to some
who would call others conspiracy
theories
well
yes but I mean honestly you know
so many conspiracy theories uh have
turned out to be true
which ones well like the hunter Biden
laptop that's true yeah yeah so yeah uh
you know that that that was a pretty big
deal there was Twitter and and and
others engaged in active suppression of
information that was relevant to the
public
um that's that's a that's a terrible
thing that happened that's like an
interference and not uh and also what
wasn't mentioned about Elon was that the
intelligence agency signed off on this
letter which was then weaponized by
people in the media who willfully lie to
manipulate this is once again a very
similar story of election interference
from intelligence agencies Democrats and
the media there is no country unless
these people are criminally charged
arrested and removed from polite Society
because they're criminals who engage in
criminal activity but if you consider
that it's just an accident in their sawi
oh they're sorry
now I feel bad Shameless I mean it was
let him go it was a mistake you know
that's why Penn State I feel like
they're not sorry they're just like we
did some stuff wrong and we change our
own rules so we won't com we won't do
anything wrong again but we don't know
that they've changed the rules to per
now they've changed the rules to permit
them to act the way they did you know
they've just legalized their actions
probably and I love this rationalization
that you get from the left where they'll
say okay like we yes we were vehemently
wrong about this every step of the way
and we did try to ruin people's lives
and we did misinform the American people
but like we didn't mean to yeah we saw
yeah exactly we saw during the pandemic
we saw it during Russia gate we see this
with the left all of the time it's like
okay well if you're wrong about
everything all the time I kind of don't
care if you were lying or not I know
that I can't trust you ever they're just
sorry you figured it out they're not
sorry they didn't exactly and this is
how it works you never admit you're
wrong you move on to the next scam
that's how scammers work right a scammer
doesn't go like okay so like
wasn't really a Nigerian prince but I am
trying to call you about your car's
extended warranty so they just move from
the Nigerian prince thing to your car's
extended a horse without ever talking to
you about the car admitting that you
they were wrong yeah it's like you're
not a Nigerian prince click yeah fun
Rings again I'd like to talk to you
about your car's extended warranty
really to go well I feel like we should
just start our stop watches and see what
big Revelations gonna come out to
distract us from this because that's I
feel like how you can tell time in
America well more importantly I wonder
what the next big election interference
is going to be in 2024 well what lie
will they push next well and this is
this is what's so wild right so over 10
percent of Biden voters according to
surveys not only did not know that the
hunter Biden laps top story was uh a
thing because of how suppressed it was
they said if they had known about it
they would not have voted for Joe Biden
okay the idea that 10 of Biden voters
surveyed if that really does apply to
the rest of the voice the population
would not have swayed the election
what's your what's your Source uh
Washington examiner there was a poll
that they published right after these I
want to make sure we have the number
correct yeah yeah I I actually think it
might have been more than ten percent
more than pull this up I remember
Rasmussen had one that was like six or
seven percent okay either way either way
it's a substantial amount it's enough
people to theoretically swing the
election depending on where they're
they're centered or where they're based
now that's all evil that is evil that is
clear corporate interference in American
elections and I would say that that's
actually more heinous than uh
non-government actors in Russia spending
forty six thousand dollars on Facebook
ads not all of which were from one
single partisan perspective on top of
that we had actual elected leaders
referring to that as an act of War an
act of War so what do we call it when
American corporations do the exact same
thing on a much larger scale which
there's actually good polling data to
indicate did sway the election well and
they're doing it on a much larger 100
multi-hundred million dollar almost
billion dollar scale when it comes to
groups like the center for Tech and
Civic life getting money from the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative when you talk
about the lie that they're going to
Peddle I think Universal mail and voting
I'm sure there'll be some sort of Public
Health Emergency that necessitates
rolling that up but it's interesting I
put a story up today so obviously the
center for for Tech and Civic life the
Zuckerberg funded election group they
had to sort of Rebrand since they came
under a bunch of scrutiny during the
2020 election but one of their their new
groups it's called The Alliance for
election Excellence it's a very good
name but they're now giving they have an
80 million dollar War chest and they're
now giving like half a million dollar
grants to local election offices across
the country and they're buying them
catch this office space to store mail-in
ballots and to also store election
tabulation machines so they're up to
their old price of them so I know I'm
sure very altruistic anything Mark
Zuckerberg does is marked by by altruism
and if it's not altruistic it was an
accident
election side because like yeah me and
my wife like peace out we're done but no
they just use another Shady nonsense
you're giving it to someone to give to
them you remember when he he was like
legal Health Alliance in covid
Zuckerberg reportedly gave all his money
away or something like that what but it
turned out he put it in an LLC to avoid
the death tax and the inheritance tax
something like that happened I could be
wrong but they were like wow
Zuckerberg's giving away all his money
and they were like yeah to a company so
that when he dies it doesn't get taxed
at 50 yeah it was like the Patagonia
thing their founder was like we're gonna
give all of our money away and it's like
oh actually they get a huge tax credit
for doing this they're not just they're
not here to save the planet they're here
to help themselves and the sad thing is
if he said it he was doing it to avoid
taxes it would be way cooler right like
I might actually appreciate that if he's
gonna lie about giving it to the poor
okay well you're a slimy guy you're
lying about giving money to the poor if
he was just honest about it look this
horrible government that does horrible
things and is going to spend this money
on nonsense isn't going to get a penny
of it I go ah yeah I get it I understand
they they all do this these wealthy
individuals will be like I'm gonna
donate 99 of my money and then like
you'll get a guy named you know Sheamus
Coughlin who's a billionaire yeah and
he'll be like I'm gonna donate 999
million dollars to charity and then
he'll start a charity called the shaman
Sheamus Coughlin foundation and I'll
donate it to himself exactly that way he
can write off all of the income and then
have it as a non-profit and then keep
the money a full fun fact there are
actually studies that show inheritance
taxes increase income inequality because
the lower classes inherit a larger
percentage of their net worth than the
upper class does and so usually what
inheritance taxes actually do is just
completely screw Farmers over because a
person has a farm that they spent their
entire life working on and yeah like the
farm and the farming equipment are
rather expensive but a lot of these
people are just making a normal middle
class living and then they have to pay
this insane inheritance tax before they
can pass it on to their children so they
end up having a sell their their land
off yeah that's why a lot of firms go
into trust right they do it to avoid
having to go through the process or
llc's like trusts clever ways they they
uh avoid paying taxes but for those who
can't avoid it or for those who don't
know better than to avoid it or even
people you know outside of the context
of farming who just have a house and
they don't know how to leave it to their
their kids without avoiding the taxes
they end up getting screwed Millionaires
and billionaires are going to find their
way around any set of taxes right just
like Zuckerberg did but poor people are
not buying things as a rich person is
not the same as buying things as a poor
person nope if you're a poor person who
needs a car you save up 10 you go to the
car dealership you say I want this you
know twenty thousand dollar car they say
okay it's two thousand dollars down and
then you take out a loan for the other
18 and then you got to pay a certain
percentage on it so you are losing money
on your asset by the time you finally
get that asset you've ended up paying
double for it so you've lost tens of
thousands if you're rich you walk in
write a check boom you have the car the
car's value effectively stays the same
let's use a better example like like
land or property yeah if you're poor and
you're buying a house you get a loan you
pay interest you lose money to the banks
to acquire this after 30 years or
whatever you finally pay it off you're
like I did it I paid off my house and
you've lost twice the value of the house
in the purchase so basically you only
retain half of the value of your of your
own money you're rich and you got cash
snap your fingers you buy it you retain
all the value not the same thing and
then they do these tricks where you know
they can give the money to their own
kids well and who gets the value the
rich the banks yep the Federal Reserve I
guess but I guess this isn't supposed to
be occupied Wall Street cast we are
talking about elections don't complain
about but hey you know uh Steve talks
about the stuff all the time I'm gonna
say yeah he wants to tax all these
people I don't agree with these wealth
Tech stuff but Steve's he's adamant on
we don't have to because they're not
they're good they're going to use the
money to fund all of these groups like
true election rigging groups whatever
you want to call them and I've always
supported that was one of the first
policies that Steve had put back when I
was in high school watching him speak I
think at the Oxford Union and I was like
this is so right and what's so funny is
you know put aside I always loved
talking to to Uber drivers Democrat
Republican and like that's the one issue
that they can always get behind is that
taxing the rich but actually taxing them
substantively and meaningfully and
making the policy so it's not just that
the hyper-connected rich uh get they
don't have to pay the furniture but it's
everyone but then the government gets
the money and gives it to the FBI yeah
exactly so therein lies the problem you
have to defund the FBI well yeah that's
my concerned with a child I think sex
trafficking operation but the rest of
the FBI yes yeah well like with the FBI
with all of these institutions and it's
not even just the Deep States the
government overall as Tim alluded to it
it's all incredibly corrupt they spend
our money horribly I understand what
you're saying wealth taxes made me
nervous for a number of reasons I think
you know in principle my main belief I
would say economically is is in property
ownership and I don't just mean that in
like a strictly laissez-faire sense I
think the more people who own property
the better we offer the better off we
are as a country I think it gives
everyone a stake in the future you know
a country of property owners is
obviously better than a country of
renters I'm a very big believer in the
middle class and lower class being able
to own property and I think a lot has to
be done in order to make that a
realistic possibility for people in the
future but
with wealth taxes I mean
the issue is with unrealized capital
gains you're you're taxing something
that doesn't actually exist yet so then
someone has to sell off a portion of
their company and if it was just people
who were Ultra Ultra ultra wealthy I
could sort of understand but that always
trickles down right anytime the
government says we're only going to tax
people above a certain limit they end up
lowering that bar until eventually you
were all paying that way the initial
income tax was like three percent and it
was only for the ultra wealthy and now
here we are with poor people paying 20
yep I want to jump to this next story we
got this tweet from Mario novel he says
breaking CNN on Trump's exoneration
quote it is regardless devastating to
the FBI and to a degree it does
exonerate Donald Trump Jake Tapper he
says is CNN becoming less biased will
other major media follows certainly play
this clip of Jake Tapper for you
regardless the report is now here it has
dropped and it might not have produced
everything of what some Republicans
hoped for it is regardless devastating
to the FBI and to a degree it does
exonerate Donald Trump who would agree
they're still so scared they're still so
scared of liberals they can't just say
Trump did not collude with Russia he
says to a degree it proves he didn't
clue with Russia no it literally proves
he didn't collude with Russia dream die
no my friend I want this to be true so
badly exactly it no it does not
exonerate Trump to a degree Trump was
exonerated about all of this long ago
what it does to a degree is indict you
and everyone else in the media who is
parroting this nonsense and the the
mainstream media language around this is
so funny to me AP put out this this
article about it and said the findings
aren't flattering for the FBI like like
it's not looking good we don't want to
say anything but it's not great and they
say like uh that the investigator was
done without was done with that uh
without adequate bias and routinely they
routinely ignored or rationalized
evidence that undercut the premise so
the whole time they were aware that this
was not worth it and they were like but
we're gonna keep going literally what
happened was they said they said Trump
has a p-tape and we said care to
elaborate further and they said no do
you guys remember the Huffington Post
story about somewhere some video of
trump doing something yes I saw that
that was killing me that was killing me
uh but no that's literally what happened
right and they're never gonna admit they
were wrong as I said you know it's it's
just one scam after another move on
doesn't matter doesn't matter how many
times they're proven wrong does not
matter how here's the here's the story
from 2018 the hunt for every Trump
reporter's white whale the elevator tape
it says there it was some 1500 words
into a story published in The Daily
Beast the infamous Donald Trump elevator
tape not the tape itself but the first
reference the bombshell tape of trump in
an elevator what is the the Walsh
journal the AP and others had Chase if
it hit that may not even exist a certain
contingent of journalists who'd spent
months searching for something worth
publishing all that really mattered was
the formal unveiling of the tape rumor
to the public it was basically nothing a
story about literally nothing
and they all chased after it the famous
quote was that was the Tweet where it
was like somewhere something exists what
it is we don't know what it's about not
sure but Trump was there we believe it
Trump took the elevators not taking the
stairs it's not healthy this is a real
scandal
they were desperate to find anything
they were desperate to find it and look
we know well it was it was very
difficult to attack Trump on the basis
of his policies because
Alvin and both tweeted a tape might
exist of trump doing something in an
elevator though exactly where that
somewhere is and what that something
might be no one in media can say that's
because known in media seems to have
seen the tape or is even confident it
exists what what does that mean they
were they were writing articles about
this imagine somebody walks into The
Newsroom and they're like I got huge
news I just want like Trump may have
been an elevator at some point with a
camera doing something I don't know what
he did when he did it or why it was
filmed and they're like whoa can we find
that tape yes I just want this to have
been someone on his campaign who's like
I know one liberal journalist I'm gonna
start this rumor and just see where it
goes and they read these tweets and
they're like I started that they can't
tell anyone because somewhere there's a
video of Donald Trump well they're like
they're they're children it's
embarrassing it is embarrassing that a
news Outlet would publish that yeah
something so you know it happens
somewhere this is literally when you
were in third grade and didn't read the
book and then you got called in front of
the class to do your book report you're
like yeah something happened when
somewhere they were like I got big news
a video
may exist if Sheamus Coughlin no no
doing something now what he was doing I
don't know where it happened I'm not so
sure but a video exists if shame is
doing something somewhere in fact quite
literally what you're watching right now
is a video of Shameless doing something
somewhere it's not bad it's just
literally Sheamus talking about politics
but plausible but imagine this imagine
this you could literally play the the
media was so insane
I could I could claim there is a
shocking video of Sheamus Coughlin doing
something somewhere and then everyone's
like whoa I wonder what it could be and
they imagine Sheamus like juggling
bowling pins or skydiving who knows when
in reality I'm referring to Tim cast
iron my biggest scandals were juggling
bowling pins we didn't say it was a
scandal we just said you're doing
something oh exactly and then everyone
turns into a scandal by imagining the
craziest thing yes it really it really
is bizarre as I guess I'm technically a
journalist and it pains me to say that
because that's a rough one I know
whenever you're meeting new people and
I'm introducing myself like what do you
do I'm like I'm a journalist I'm sorry
I'm not gonna like smear you
um but it really is bizarre to me right
like running with a story like that when
there's really nothing to report and I
think what we're gonna see start to kind
of unfold which obviously we all know
here but obviously the hunter Biden hard
drive story in terms of the collusion
with big Tech and the FBI the CIA that
letter I think that really proves that
there is sort of a merger really I'd
call it an axis of Evil between these
assets of the deep State and Tech
platforms but I think the third
component to that really is the
mainstream media and I think we've
always known they've laundered talking
points on behalf of the federal
government but I think this case again
yes it's Vindication yes we know Trump
didn't collude with Russia but this is
like clear and controvertible evidence
that I don't think we typically get to
see it so plain front and center at
least you know us mere American people
us mere mortals us non-elites
um so I think we're going to start to
see just like that Hunter Biden story
has sort of started to unfurl and you
get good tidbits every now and then I
think there's going to be a lot more
coming out about how the media has
really just taken whether it's fbic you
name it their talking points and just
repeated them mindlessly I got I got
good news though take a look at this
based CNN's ratings are now below
Newsmax amazing Newsmax has surpassed
CNN look at this 8 P.M 9 pm news max is
like yes we knew we could do it meeting
CNN I mean to be fair
CNN's been collapsing but look Newsmax
is considered more conservative right
they get smeared and attacked by the
corporate press and now they're so
they're displacing them CNN tried to
play dirty games and now they will cease
to exist but have you considered that
somewhere someone might have done
something in CNN may possibly have some
of that footage also they're sorry yeah
they're actually I'm sorry I can't
confirm sorry there isn't there is a
video of Anderson Cooper doing Anderson
Cooper doing something somewhere well
the thing is I'm not sure and where it
is I don't know but the video does exist
and if we can find it oh boy oh that'll
be really bad it'll be really bad let's
write 27 articles about it for the next
three years every day the white whale a
video that no one knows anything like do
you know how many videos of trump in an
elevator there are probably 17 000 yeah
because all of these different Casino
elevators have uh have have cameras most
big uh high security like high rises and
penhouses have cameras every time Trump
got in an elevator there's a video of
him in an elevator doing something oh I
just want to know how many journalists
spent hours watching like leaked or like
footage they finagled away from someone
it's Trump just like standing in the
elevator like any second now he's gonna
do something crazy like there there's no
commitment to truth there's no
commitment to reality or honesty I got I
mean look I'm a cartoonist I read jokes
and I do political commentary I'm not a
journalist not not anything of the sort
I ca and I given my state in life as
someone who makes jokes I could never
imagine grabbing a story like that and
repeating that to people because you got
to be responsible with your platform I
think this is like the two-sided nature
of Journalism today right like they
believe there is a reality that they
live in and they are here to disprove
your reality they don't believe we all
live in a common shared reality they
believe that if they can create enough
evidence of their own belief system you
have to admit that their worldview is
right and you have to conform to it I
think that's the the strange thing about
so much of essentially content creation
that gets passed off as journalism today
it's about arguing that the things you
believe are wrong because my world view
is is necessitated on the fact that the
these things I know to be true that
Trump is evil be colluded with Russia
and that if we vote for him the
country's falling apart and in reality
even if you don't like everything Trump
does he is not this like
you know terrible person that should
send you into hysterics well yeah I mean
none of these journalists or journalists
like 98 of the people who call
themselves journalists or political
commentators or their bloggers or
something like that they write opinion
pieces or they give you your perspective
about something on television literally
I'm telling you they're real journalists
they're real journalists and you're not
and this is the thing I I am saying this
and I actually am willing to stand by
this there there is a large percentage
of the people who call themselves
journalists who minus like running a
business and producing animation do kind
of the same thing I do which is read
articles learn about the issues do a bit
of research and then comment on them
they don't actually go investigate
issues on the ground they don't do
interviews with people they don't try to
find the truth uh and like granted I do
try to find the truth so that's one
difference but they will just read
things online on like their news feed or
maybe they have someone who looks into
articles for them and they'll start
commenting on it but they're not like
investigating the way you want a
journalist to they're just reading
things so they can give an opinion about
it well I think the cherry pick facts so
that they can serve their own reality
and that's the only way to describe it
they will say well we think there's a
video of trump so therefore he's a
suspicious character so therefore you
should trust us when we say he did all
of these things wrong I think they are
completely uh biased to or they're
completely blind to their own bias
because it's so deeply embedded in their
worldview do you think that like yeah
you know what I'm actually going to
Google this right now I want to see like
what the bare minimum is for referring
to yourself as a journalist there's
nothing there's nothing so I could just
amateur because you know I like I did go
to the March for Life for for Tim cast
and interview people like generalized
journalists I mean I interviewed people
about why they were at the March for
Life so I guess I'm a journalist I'm
gonna change my Twitter bias and I'm
going to add journalists to it right now
I think there used to be a standard
right like a journalist is different
than a reporter which is different than
a writer or that's just different than a
columnist but now it's a blanket term
for anyone who pushes who who pushes
this information which is information or
or publishes something that resembles
news news adjacent we might call it I'm
gonna so I'm adding journalists to my
bio and in fact I'm adding journalists
first and foremost
oh I don't have enough words left all
right I'm just gonna put journalist in
my bio there boom it's done yeah I'm
literally a journalist now where's my
blue check mark I don't know
I I think you have to create one I think
you can buy one blue check mark is
something you just buy I know now you
just buy it I should have done some some
journalism on that hold on don't be too
hard on yourself is surge the only
non-journalist here right now that's so
important I'm currently doing journalism
right now I'm always doing journalism
just by being alive I do no I'm just
kidding I I think that's the hard thing
we have moved uh one of the benefits of
the digital age is how quickly we can
get new information out there and the
new formats that we get to discuss news
and have commentary I mean this podcast
exists essentially like four different
opinion writers talking at the same time
giving your opinion as opposed to
reading four different opinion columns
written around the same time about an
issue and that's more fun on the other
hand we have um I think sort of grade
the classifications of news media
because anyone can be a journalist and
also no one truly has any journalistic
ethics or obligations I mean I think
people do I don't want to be too hard on
all reporters there are some great
journalists who do fantastic work but
like I don't think you should just be
like I'm out here with my cell phone
recording the street therefore I'm a
journalist unless you are putting some
effort in you're researching you're
trying to find the truth you're talking
to people whose opinion you don't like I
think that's what bothers me the most so
many people go into this sphere just to
talk to people who they like themselves
and uh who produce talking points
similar to the ones they would produce
if they were the one being interviewed I
feel like you can really cross Supply
that critique to virtually every
industry in America in the sense of this
whole refrain of you know trust the
experts right the expert journalists at
the New York Times and the CNN cnns and
the Washington posts of the world
they're actually not our intellectual
betters and superiors and I think the
House of Cards Right This ability to
enforce narratives like the Russia
collusion hoax like rests on this sort
of worshiping this idea that oh because
you work for the New York Times and you
have journalists in your bio and you
have a blue check mark we must believe
what you say because you're from the
federal government and you're telling us
how to mitigate a pandemic we must
listen to you and what you're saying and
I I think it's sort of they just want
the American people again who are so
dumb because they see an article on
Facebook they're just going to start
supporting some candidate
um but I really think they just want us
to blindly
put our faith in every aspect of our
life right over our bodies what we
believe what we think what we eat you
name it
um into our you know intellectual
superiors into this Elite ruling class
and I think frankly that was what covet
proved that this Elite ruling class that
is so smart and Joe Biden who you know
that class of people used to mock I
always thought they'd always say oh
Donald Trump made a fool of America on
the world stage and I always like this
concept of the world stage like they
care so much with their you know
globalist Brethren think of them and
what America looks like but then you
take a step back and you're like okay
well even if I'm gonna run with that
Paradigm uh Joe Biden has made us look
like a complete idiot and just a dismal
failure on the world's stage I just I
just want to point out as you all were
talking I was I was doing journalism
I found the footage this is a still
image Donald Trump in the elevator look
how shocked everyone is oh my God
they're they're shocking uh they're
they're so surprised that his behavior
As Trump is is yelling about something
that is so so shocking this footage that
I can't even describe to you what
actually happened in that elevator trust
me I've seen it that is legitimately one
of my favorite one of my favorites of
course this is an art an AI generated
image of Donald Trump in an elevator I
just typed it into my journey
AI generated journalism
one of my favorite things you're
mentioning a lot of things they were
saying about Trump when they had an
anonymous source reporting that Trump
said something completely insane on
Veterans Day like I frankly hate all
veterans it was the most absurd nonsense
in the world like okay he didn't say
this Anna was from an anonymous source I
I couldn't help but laugh because you
know an anonymous source only works if
you're a trustworthy person yeah right
if there's any reason to trust you I
have seen the stories that you guys tell
when you have a named source so no I
don't trust your Anonymous sources and
frankly I think you probably made it up
yourself well and theoretically if you
had Professional Standards you'd call
the Trump White House or campaign
wherever we were in the timeline and say
hey do you care to comment on this we're
gonna run with this story you should
have a chance to respond that's supposed
to be ethical but they probably won't
and even if they do they'll say you know
the Trump campaign categorically denied
this while they shook in their boots
because they're so scared of our amazing
anonymous source who we can't tell you
anything about it's real trust us I
think that it was important to
acknowledge that this does happen in all
walks of life that's a really good point
I think there are so many institutions
that people point to when they want to
use authority to back up their arguments
I mean we see this a lot I I I'm loath
to bring it up because I know we talk
about a lot but um with the transgender
ideology movement people point to the
American Association of Pediatrics and
say well they say there are certain
things you are supposed to do they'll
point to all kinds of medical
establishments I think we have to look
back and say why do we trust these
institutions some of them may do good
work I don't know but you should look
into the institutions who's on the board
how do they assemble themselves are they
elected you have to have a certain
qualification what is their mission
statement if you just throw out the name
like this is the authority then you are
either a trying to hide the bias or B
you are not aware of the bias which in
and of itself is dangerous if you're
putting yourself in a position where
you're supposed to be giving out solid
information dude mid-journey is crazy it
is wild I just I got another one you're
doing some real journalism tonight I'm
tweeting another one let me uh let me
try and let me try and pull it up for
you so Natalie personally he's a
journalist I've never used an anonymous
source have you ever
I'm trying to think if I've actually
ever unironically used it or not you
know most of my reporting well I guess
either comes from the hunter Biden hard
drive or publicly available data that
the mainstream media won't report on
when it comes to Chinese Communist Party
infiltration because usually I'm
reporting on how the mainstream media is
compromised by the Chinese Communist
party it's a very good niche market I've
found
um but no it is it is weird it really is
funny though and like you guys are
saying like people I think for the most
part hate journalists like I get that
whenever I'm introducing myself to
people and telling them what I do for
work I have never had a positive
interaction with someone then when they
find out that I'm technically like not
really a journalist because it's Steve
Bandon and he's great then they're like
oh you're normal you're like not one of
them but people hate journalists yeah I
didn't I didn't realize but my
experience is I don't know if you've
ever had this happen but if you talk to
someone who is like Progressive or left
and who is a journalist and they like
proudly introduce themselves as a
journalist like they are the bearers of
truth I find this very fascinating like
it is definitely a cultural shift some
people do not trust the media and for
good reason but there are some people
who wear it as a badge of honor and that
is also worrisome yes and of course I
feel like we can't we have to give an
honorable mention to the like fact
Checkers of the world and the Media
Matters the media Watchdog types because
they're obviously in on the same grift
but no they call they attack me all the
time for working with Steve saying that
I'm not actually an investigative
reporter it's like fine then point to
one of my stories true prove it right
I've never been sued I've never
published or printed anything incorrect
frankly a lot of my investigations have
led to people wiping their Twitter
accounts getting fired getting removed
from boards so the evidence is there
right there's obviously action occurring
from my reporting so it's just I think
you know you brought up the transgender
movement a lot of this just I think has
to also just do with like distorting
words right like journalists doesn't
mean what it used to mean because
definitions don't really they're not
rooted in reality because everyone can
have different really versions of
reality and that's of course Amplified
by the fact that if you turn on CNN and
say oh to a degree well what what does
that mean you know it's it's not even
double speak it's just it's a whole
different language I want to jump to the
story about uh Patriot front we have
this from Newsweek white supremacist
march on DC Sparks conspiracy theory FBI
was involved so uh the group is called
Patriot front and I've seen a bunch of
people on the right say that journalists
as well as personalities that I think
Elijah Schaefer was saying that he's
really well connected on the right you
know there's a lot of people from
various different groups he's talked to
them he's interviewed them and he knows
no one associated with Patriot front I
thought that was very interesting
because you know I've been to a lot of
these events I used to go on the ground
and do a lot of reporting I've been even
a lot of people and I've never met a
single person who was associated with
whatever this group is not that I'm on
the ground in the past few years anyway
so maybe it's an it's it's new I guess
in the past five years or so but the
funniest thing about it is we have this
uh clip from Joe wrote The Joe Rogan
experience of the Patriot front March I
want to show you an image of these
individuals you can see they all have
these hats they have these masks they
all wear masks they have shields they
all wear the same things like somebody
ordered the same blue jacket like 300 of
them they all wore the same thing they
ordered the same white neck Gators the
same khakis the same boots so really
well organized I suppose and then I want
to show you what Joe Rogan had to say in
response to seeing this video I think he
was on on a show with Matt taibi good
[Laughter]
do that again what the is this is
that have you ever seen anything that
looks more where's the fat people tell
me that doesn't look like feds
right it's like the 101st Airborne
Runners these guys look at they just got
out of buds I mean what the out of
here
the so uh so I saw someone comment
you know it's not real because whenever
you see an actual right-wing militia
group they're all morbidly obese or at
least a handful of them are not all of
them and it's like that that's actually
fairly interesting now I have seen
people push back and say don't
underestimate them they like that
they're being called feds the actual the
reality is someone posted an image from
an internal FBI report where the FBI
actually warns that among the FBI half
of the agents are morbidly obese so this
act so it's actually the other way
around and the argument is the actual
white nationalists do fight and train
and and so it may be it may be real I
don't know I honestly I don't know what
to think all I know is it's weird this
group has has police protection they
were they were a lot they did this March
where they then were given an escort to
to the subway where no cleared for them
right it was cleared for them and no one
was allowed to go in after them they've
loaded into trucks under police watch
and guard and then left so Joe Rogan may
be right about this yeah we're the fat
people funny story I was actually
walking through DC and I stumbled upon
them while they were doing this so I was
taking an unintentional journalist yeah
I was doing my journalistic duties and I
had thought they were Patriot front
because I've obviously been to a lot of
trump rallies and you know been been
around and I know this isn't necessarily
evidence or fact based but you can get a
vibe from people who are there to
protest for the right reasons you know
there's just sort of a vibe to the Trump
crowd or people who are there whatever
the issue is because you can tell that
they really want to be there and they're
talking to other people who aren't
necessarily there to attend the rally
but they're trying to sort of
proselytize and like spread the cause
and spread the word and it was such an
odd Vibe and I know that's not again
doesn't mean much but I had just never
seen a group of people protesting who
were allegedly so patriotic acting the
way that they were just walking it was
so where's antifa it was bizarre how
come antifa's not protesting any of
these guys no serious question yeah
where are they at well and why do they
have a police escort right like some
when I first saw a picture that someone
was like oh it's like Charlottesville
and like the unite the right walk and I
was like this looks way more organized
than that did uh Zeke Arkham on Twitter
had this his thing and I guess he's in
law enforcement he was saying like
there's photos of them being arrested
theoretically except they all still have
their masks on and they're kneeling and
he's basically going through being like
you wouldn't let them continue to wear
their masks because you have to make
sure they're breathing when they're in
police custody like you wouldn't have
them kneeling in this position like none
of this makes sense it's almost like
you're waiting to hear like oh actually
the whole thing was staged for a movie
and they're filming it and this is what
they think this is like like it it seems
so strange especially since there are
police involved like this is not
normally how police respond to any kind
of right group extremists or not uh
demonstrating publicly they usually have
very little police police support that
was funny when Joe's like where are the
fat people at that's it's real though
that's very real
yeah I don't know what do you guys think
friends look I mean
I have no idea but it's not something
that would be shocking if it came out
right like my instinct is just to assume
that something's up at this point I I
mean there are it's almost foolish to
not actively distrust them right
so I don't know are there there's not
feds but there's stories about these
antifa guys getting picked up driven
around the block and then let go yep
that's what they do with informants I
wouldn't be surprised I mean there were
Federal FBI informants on the ground on
January 6 which apparently was also
planned so therefore the FBI knew about
it question mark like none of it makes
sense the thing about this is like it's
just so uniform they all are like in the
sunglasses and the hat and the exact
same jacket like I just really don't
think there's it's too precise for it to
seem like inorganic movement it
immediately hits like the left-wing
social media machine the you know blue
check mark the angry blue check marks on
Twitter and the mainstream media it just
I I don't know I feel like it's not even
it wasn't even about the March itself
it's how it gets rolled out and then
it's used as a pretext to start a
broader narrative about how white
supremacy and nationalism and xenophobia
are on the rise and so we you know and
then but then they made the jump we need
to crack down on you know random Twitter
user one two three right were they were
there any chance like was there any
chanting was there any demands what was
the message like I don't understand
other than the fact that it's Patriot
front like what is the theoretical
racial messaging behind this this
activity there's almost no media about
it they don't have any media presence I
don't see anything about them about
Patriot from other than stuff that's
very nicely and this specific
demonstration like I don't where is the
chanting like we got some great sound
bites from previous events really fishy
right but the media has declared that
it's a white supremacist events
right that's what that's what I think
yeah
I feel like the FBI is gonna be like it
was actually just a drill we were just
practicing to see what would happen the
FBI headquarters was literally just I
mean a block away from where they were
marching so no hold on I'm not I'm not
some kind of conspiracy theorist lunatic
who is going to say that these guys
they're protesting on Thursdays
I am not some conspiracy theory lunatic
who is going to say this is feds the
obvious explanation is these are Russian
Agents from the Kremlin
because Putin wants to reform the USSR
yes no they they they're Soviet and they
were they were sleepers and when the
Soviet Union collapsed they didn't know
because they were brainwashed and then
because Putin wants to bring the Soviet
Union back he activated the radio signal
which oh my God he triggered all of them
into acting for uh the Soviet Union just
like as a journalist that person could
never say that the United States
government did anything wrong because
being a journalists in the United States
government yeah my anonymous source told
me that think about that so I you think
about how insane
where it said somewhere something Trump
did something like that yes that starts
with like some rumor and then a bunch of
journalists who are psychopaths chase
after this insane rumor imagine what's
going to happen when someone gets an AI
generated image on their phone and they
go to a journalist and intelligence
agencies will do this and they'll be
like journalist I can't give you the
photo because I'll get arrested because
it's classified but take a look at this
and they'll show a low-res AI generated
image of Donald Trump you know juggling
bowling pins or something and then
they'll be like it's real and then
they'll be like but I can't give it to
you but you know keep it on the DL that
journalist then goes and tells their
boss I saw the picture it was Donald
Trump juggling bowling pins I swear you
know this is this is a source is good
I've checked his credentials they're
gonna go wow maybe we should run it and
then just like BuzzFeed news released
the steel dossier they will report
source that FBI confirms Donald Trump
juggles bowling pins and they'll just
walk right into fake news
that's where we're going I think that we
should start doing this on purpose
though like you should write down piece
of paper hold it up to video camera with
today's date The Story You're gonna tell
every left-wing journalist that you know
and then wait until it becomes
mainstream news and then be like by the
way that was false like I know that
sounds like spreading just information
but you should just point out that there
are leaks that that there are people who
take this information and intentionally
try to paint everyone you know in a bad
light I think it's only a matter of time
before those Tucker Carlson leaked
videos
get revealed to be deep fakes or at
least one of them because I think about
this Media Matters will publish anything
and so what someone could theoretically
do is take 10 real videos make one deep
fake video Give Them All to a leftist
organization who will publish them all
then definitively prove the Deep fake
one by showing a video of them making it
and say your fake news and you make up
stories then what happens the subject of
those defects can file a massive
defamation lawsuit for the publication
of a deep fake with with proof and then
what's going to happen is they're going
to say we didn't know it was a deep fake
and they have to argue to the court they
thought it was real because of a source
giving it to them and then the argument
can be made no they're lying we want
Discovery we think they made it
themselves and then the question is
where do they get it they're gonna have
to reveal a bunch of information and
it's going to destroy whatever smidgen
of credibility they may have had with
anybody someone tweeted at me I can't
watch right now since Ryanair but they
tweeted something to me that has 55 000
likes it was posted yesterday and it's a
Fed gets recognized and called out at
their staged Patriot front March who's
who tweeted it um this is from
um
did you retweet it no no I have not
retweeted it I can send it to you
um just retweet it it looks like like a
mega account I have no idea if it's if
it's uh legitimate or not but someone
just told me in this so it could be fun
to watch
I just don't understand like what this
protest is like I'm sorry they just
walked through DC and they didn't say
anything and then they got on the subway
banner and it said something to the
effect of I think like reclaim or
rebuild the family
extreme
hold on hold on I like this it's not a
white supremise group it's just a real
family same families or something what
does that mean like they're just a pro
family group this is a pro family
extremist group so they're getting it
wrong must have reclaimed oh shame is uh
Sheamus just retweeted it yeah right
here pull it up let's play it
you're video saving us that's not
acceptable this is the public place your
video you're trying to get us in trouble
sir you go find one I'm deleting the
video no you're not gonna touch my phone
you're not taking a video of us and I
look at my master I recognize you yeah I
know you do
so give me my phone I'm deleting the
video
this guy literally walked walked up to
him and said in the most licensed in
registration
camera you cannot film that video
no you're not gonna touch my phone
you're not taking a video of us I mean a
lot of cops would do that I don't
understand this taking two parties one
tyranny recording
where is uh so this is from yesterday
where where uh James O'Keefe's trying to
get a whistleblower where where's antifa
man antifa the one time we actually need
your help to go out and film these guys
and figure out who they are y'all are
nowhere to be found but maybe that's the
limits test antifa is not there
therefore this is not real like that
it's like yeah exactly the feds aren't
going to go film themselves why would
Andrew film Patriot front dude fat on
fed crime makes me so sad I wish they
got along better you ever see hear those
stories about like the FBI and the DEA
stinging each other yes like the DEA is
trying to sell drugs to the FBI and then
like freeze federal law enforcement wait
so are we wait what's going on when I
was a kid there was a three million
dollars when I was a kid there was like
a car at the end of our block being
super sketchy uh and so my mom called
the police she's like look there's
something really weird going on I don't
know what what it is and then the police
came and it turned out that they were
undercover cops like pretending to
commit a crime to like try to entrap
somebody or catch them or something so
we turned uh we we turned the feds
against each other
my mom called the police on the police
well they are actually terrorizing the
neighborhood by pretending
anything
really
what's with this lurking car yeah yeah
she was not like she did not call the
cops often but it was uh Let's uh we'll
jump to this next story we got some
timcast.com Bud Light to release camo
print bottles
they're like help yeah that come on take
a look at this they're doing this on the
Eva Pride they're going with camo for
pro wow Bud Light sales wow at the end
of uh at the end of uh May 6th was down
27.7 and you can see all of their uh
Anheuser uh uh Bush's Brands ABI Brands
and Anheuser uh Bush inbev have dropped
and this is what the street says new Bud
Light data suggests outrage against
company is waning what does that really
mean what the reason why sales aren't
getting any lower is because they've
lost already around 30 percent of their
sales so close to one-third let's just
say a quarter of their of their
customers have dropped them
as this spreads it will probably stay
around this number based a lot of people
don't care a lot of I went to a grocery
store they had Bud Light right in front
I didn't even I didn't even think twice
about it there was uh it was like have a
barbecue like have go out and Grill and
have tacos and then it was a bunch of
stuff like taco shells and I was like
whatever and then the whole there was a
row with both sides was all Bud Light
right and coolers and I thought I
thought it was funny I was like oh look
at that all the Bud Light and then it
related to later I was like oh wait they
moved all the Bud Light to the front of
the store and it was on sale I just I
love how sorry I always kick this thing
I'm A Hazard I I love just the the
blatant hysterical overcompensation
they're like get no we're not gay we're
army guys yeah no we're army guys now
yeah for sure look at us I got camel
beer we're camo now funny
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait last
week camo is it Navy camo
um
the brand is blue so they might go for
the navy blue I love the thing everybody
was mentioning like the Navy made blue
camo it's like you fall in the water and
no one can see you oh my gosh like
what's the point of that they're like
hold on we have to push away from this
reputation let's do something manly
military service I got it it cuts to
their commercial in the Navy like what
is the best military branch we have a
great idea no I think this is sort of a
crazy answer I hope that anyone can see
that this is such a gross way to try to
sell your product off the military
Stolen Valor a little bit it's a little
bit if Bud Light really wanted to sell
their products this is what they should
do and I know it's gonna sound sane but
I think they should just start
infiltrating infiltrating Pinterest with
like a thousand ways to cook using only
Bud Light like worlds of Honor programs
right to be like it's cheap you can get
Bud Light very it's not expensive right
now some places you can get it for free
dude and you can cook it in your slow
cooker you can do all these things but
you have to use Bud Light eventually
that's the only way to sell your product
you have to pretend that you're not
actually a drink you're just actually
some random ingredients I am getting
more and more Angry reading about this I
am seriously pissed off reading this
Anheuser-Busch will produce bottles of
the camouflage print and images of the
folds of Honor program which provides
educational scholarships for children
and spouses have fallen and disabled
American military service members and
First Responders according to the
executive no no no no no no no earmuffs
if your children are in the room you
have been warned you Bud Light go
yourselves this is probably 10
times more offensive than anything they
could have done they spit in your face
they mock you behind the scenes they
talk in private about how they know
you're mad and they refuse to apologize
and then they say I know let's shove
disabled military veterans in their
faces as if that will absolve them of
their responsibilities this is the is
the most offensive way in my opinion to
respond to the backlash well the first
thing they did was bring up 911. yeah
seriously wild they're like we're not
gay 911 Army
we ride horses 911 Army also this uh
Foundation I feel sad for them because
they're going to also get backlash like
nope don't care legitimately doing
trying to do good work like why would
you accept a partnership with Bud Light
right now like I don't care how much you
think they're worth this is a bad idea
yeah if they if if a company wants to
align themselves with Bud Light that the
only thing this European company is
doing it's not an American company is
repeatedly kicking Us in the stomach
over and over and over again
just don't buy their products
I mean trying to placate American
consumers and I think it dovetails
honestly kind of perfectly with the
whole Russia hoax it's like we're gonna
lie to you we're gonna offend you and
your values for this long period of time
but you still need to like buy into the
American system you still need to trust
the authorities you still need to trust
the FBI you still need to buy our
products we're not going to change
anything yeah we'll give you the Durham
report we'll vindicate you slightly yeah
we'll partner with like you know some
911 charity but it's like no we're done
with you like you said I I won't use the
word but it's
Corporate America they needed to they
needed to come out and be like hey look
we're really sorry about this we had a
you know marketing VP who wanted to it
won't work endorse and we we think the
campaign was not appropriate for our
audience we didn't mean to offend
anybody so we hope you'll stick with us
we will not be pursuing campaigns like
this in the future I'd have been like oh
those that was really straightforward
and very nice of them instead they just
keep laughing behind the scenes and
they're getting what they're they're
doing these tricks to try and make it
seem like sales are returning and all
they keep doing is instead of assuming
responsibility they absolutely refuse to
say we were wrong
so I got it we were wrong sorry guys we
that was we were wrong and they're just
digging their they're digging deeper and
deeper and deeper I gotta be honest I I
think saying they're wrong still would
not undo the damage I think a lot of
dudes are just gonna see this is a gay
brand from now on it's going to gross
them out for that reason they're not
going to want to be seen as gay or
they're not going to want to support it
so they're not going to buy the beer
that's it if they came out we're like
hey uh sawi was an accident like our
wonderful elected leaders do and the
people of the FBI it's still it still
wouldn't do anything I think these woke
Marketing Executives though their their
brains are so infested like they have
drunk the Kool-Aid on all of these
social issues that I also think that
they also don't even actually want to
make money for their companies right
that's not like in their DNA right doing
that as another cardinal sin that you
can't engage with and so I think these
people have always used these platforms
to push social agendas so they're not
gonna apologize because they're like no
we're using this venue this Avenue for
the explicit purpose that we were hired
for and I'm sure they have AI beyond
belief in terms of their hiring
processes so you're self-selecting for
these loons they already disavowed Dylan
Mulvaney behind the scenes but they
refuse to do it
up above the fold they refuse to do it
in a statement they're going to their
investors they're going to the
Distributors and saying we don't have
anything to do with this we disavow but
then the customers who are angry they're
like ignore those people they don't
matter instead we'll make a camo print
and say disabled veterans over and over
again there you go that'll get our
customers they want it to be like now if
you aren't taking our beards because you
hate disabled veterans where it could be
you you're like I just haven't forgiven
you for the past I mean I wish they
would just go dark you know what I mean
I wish they would just stop for a while
let yourself Fade Into the evil then I
think people won't forget I think you're
right but I think trying to start
another campaign is only digging further
into the hole right like now it seems
like you are just acting in the most
smarmy way you're insulting military
veterans you're insulting the people who
want to support military veterans your
support you're insulting your audience
and you're not making yourself more
likable in the process like nothing is
going to repair this the best thing they
could do is to just stop talking for a
while something funny Sheamus no nothing
something you want to share
nothing sir just gave me a piece of
paper with an idea on it that I also had
earlier about it so you admit that you
steal his ideas
no it's it's it's a cartoon that uh
might be worthwhile it's about Bud Light
I'll mention after the show we wouldn't
want to spoil it but they've totally
tanked themselves it's really
embarrassing what they're doing is it
was super gross but they've continued to
be disgusting
the I don't see a way out of this for
them man I really don't if they're
unbelievably fortunate
people will forget but that's probably
not no it's just they keep they keep you
know the best thing could have done is
nothing if they did nothing if they made
no commercial no Clydes Gill Clydesdale
no 911 no folds of honor and just
literally said guys shut up and we just
drop all marketing and we're just gonna
sit back and then everyone would be like
well you know they did that thing that
one time I'm not gonna buy and then it
would have just tapered off instead
they're like can we every week punch our
customers figuratively in the face
what's also yeah it's just wild like as
if that's they're going for this
low-hanging fruit right that they know
people agreed which is really insulting
like 911 is something you're supposed to
have reverence for because a lot of
people died it was an attack on American
soil to be like oh you know what will
come out as like anti-911 or caring
about the fact that 9 11 happened and
that'll make up for the fact that we
pissed off all of our customers and
they'll start to relate to us again as
insanely insulting it's like insanely
insulting it's it's it's it's cultural
to not buy this product yeah there's
there's video there's someone posted a
photo with a CVS swear it's on sale they
brought all the beer to the front
they're like on clearance I went to a
liquor store and I was like oh are they
going to put a Bud Light I didn't sound
like where's the Bud Light that's and
then right there right by the door it
said Bud Light sale sale yeah all of it
on sale and you walk in and they have a
big shelf trying to get rid of it the
product won't move yeah it's good I saw
somebody sent me last thing on Twitter
it's like 4.95 for a 30 rack wow that's
crazy we had uh some of the staff here
were mentioning that they were at a
local bar and they asked the bartender
bartender said they can't move it at all
so they took it off tap and put core's
light in because nobody will buy it you
can't move a product what are you gonna
do and this is what people don't realize
though and this is part of why it's been
so effective everyone's arguing oh this
is such a such a good move by
conservatives on the part of the culture
or or this is such a huge victory in the
culture where on behalf of conservatives
I don't know how much of this is
actually culture war in the sense that
people who are invested in culture and
politics are paying attention to it and
strategizing so much as it's just normal
people being grossed out well I think
that's part of it it's a Grassroots uh
indication of the culture war that that
it's not just about people who are in
positions that are adjacent to the media
it is about what the public actually
will tolerate what they want I mean we
talk about all time voting with your
dollar this is the ultimate vote with
your dollar moment they don't want
companies like Bud Light essentially
making fun of them and assuming they'll
take whatever advertising is doled out
to them and they'll go along with it and
I think that's a really powerful moment
I mean in some ways it is I think
something a lot of conservatives will
look back on and say like we had an
influence like yes I'm sure anheuser-bus
is suffering they're about to face
massive layoffs there are probably uh
really serious Financial repercussions
and there are people at Bud Light who
don't deserve that right who didn't who
were never in a position to make these
decisions on the other hand I'm really
grateful that as a culture there was
something that we drew a line at well
it's that but again I
I think a lot of this just boils down to
the fact that a man in a dress is very
off-putting it's a very off-putting
thing and it's not so much people going
I'm insulted by the fact that this
Advertiser is trying to shove this down
my throat and doesn't understand who I
am as an Advertiser or as a customer I
think it's just them going gross yeah I
don't want that it doesn't have to be
one Union they just all collectively
decided this was too far that they don't
want to keep going with this and they
think that's something that uh you know
people talk about the pendulum swing and
with cultures we become more Progressive
or you know whatever else like this is
one of those moments where I start to
feel like it's swinging back the other
way we're going to start slowly moving
towards center after years and years of
pushing everyone to these extremes they
went too far I want to jump to this
story here we got a tweet from Gwen
Hogan outside ps17 in Williamsburg kids
chant quote we support Asylum Seekers
but not on school grounds you've got to
hear it to believe it
you hear that they're kind of just like
trailing off like muttering let me just
say this is there's a few ways I see
this and this is these kids one probably
we're told the chances have no idea
what's going on two it's like basically
them chanting thank you government for
hitting me twice instead of Thrice like
the government is forcing illegal
immigrants into your into your schools
and you're like that part's okay just
not in my school please do it to
somebody else not me also uh this this
is so embarrassing this is why
conservatives lose right they're buying
into the framing that you're buying into
their framing by by apologizing in your
statement was like we're like look we're
not against Asylum Seekers okay like we
conservatives it's New York I I
understand that these are New York
government can I have another I know but
they're arguably debating from like a
conservative position this is something
people would call right wing like oh
yeah you don't want them uh on school
grounds how big it of you it's like well
they're coming out and saying they're
against that but they still feel this
need to apologize thank you I think you
guys want to mixed up Sheamus these are
Urban liberals who are standing outside
cheering for for quote unquote Asylum
Seekers and then being like but like why
in my school yeah maybe it's just talk
you should do it to someone else I guess
maybe more like the Martha's Vineyard
thing yeah I feel like for me it's like
don't we get mad at the left when they
make young children who are confused
about their gender identity testify
before their state legislature saying
like if you don't allow this medical
intervention to be passed then I will
personally suffer like don't we not like
it when we use children for our talking
points why are we bringing small
children out here to say please don't
send adult I assume they're adult Asylum
Seekers to our school like why are they
having to have this battle why is no
adult fighting for them also I mean just
the fact that you would have to preface
this with I'm not bad I don't have the
bad opinion but I don't want them here
well you're gonna lose because you're
already starting from a position of
sorry
sorry I'm sorry
yeah that does it it's like thank you
the government they have another yeah
yeah I saw I'm sorry so this is what
happens I think this story is actually a
really great example of modern politics
in that these Urban liberals say it's
okay that the government does bad things
just please do it to other people yeah
so the government says we want to do a
bunch of bad stuff they say okay so long
as it goes over there yeah I think
you're right instead of just saying no
don't do the bad thing to anybody well
it's like um it's like what we saw with
Martha's Vineyard that was hysterical
they were freaking out like we can't
handle all of these people really it was
like four dozen exactly and how did you
do this to us if any community in the
country could handle it it was Martha's
Vineyard they're like round them up get
rid of them but you know there's like no
organic support for the issue when they
roll out the children I remember they
would always do the school walkouts at
first that started with the gun violence
and they had I remember at my high
school
um I forgot what shooting it was but
they had a what they staged a walk out
out of class except the administration
like sanctioned it and literally gave
them a special space to hold it it's
like this were you walking out on the
school I worked for put it on the
official schedule exactly and then they
did the same with the climate change
walk out and to be frank I think that's
why they're pushing
um a bunch of this transgender you know
gay stuff on kids because I think they
realized the way that they sort of
mainstreamed a lot of these climate
change and school shooting issues was by
getting the kids behind it and having do
these walkouts and mass protests they're
like if we can get the young kids you
know drinking the Kool-Aid on this issue
right exactly but it's like uh
it's like South Park when they're like
What's Going On We're protesting the war
okay yay no school yeah this looks like
the teacher said kids were at 11 we're
all gonna go protesting because they're
like okay I guess and the funny thing is
the kids don't even have any
enthusiasms
wait a minute they like they really
don't care to say words and some of the
kids are laughing clearly not paying
attention but I'm just like I don't know
I'm not in school what a crazy proposal
I don't know that the specifics but to
even have like Asylum Seekers on school
grounds like the fact that that's
something that we're even debating that
there needs to be a protest about I mean
like that's hard but but there aren't
any Asylum Seekers anywhere because none
of these people are Asylum Seekers
they're adult adult male economic
migrants yeah they're not Asylum I I
doubt a single one of them is an asylum
Seeker they are men who are told online
that they can come to the United States
because the borders are open and there
are jobs they go to the border and then
they ask and they talk to reporters and
the reporters like why are you here and
they're like because there's jobs
no I think that is what happens sorry I
can't fix this UFO uh I I think again I
have to go back to we don't like it when
the left trots out children to argue
their talking points so even if you're
trying to say like this is a slightly
um you know an immigration
restrictionist talking point why are we
making the children do it we have to
hold ourselves the same standards that
we hold other people to and I think
you're right I don't think these kids
these kids were like hey we can go
outside we're gonna look film us for
social media haha hilarious like they
don't care and I appreciate that about
them right like their children they just
want to go to school and hang out with
their friends that's why we don't drag
them before probably didn't incite this
protest we can't be sure but yeah no
it's just some some uh social studies
teacher who's like I'm gonna tell you
about civil Civic Disobedience I made
these signs for you to hold I had a
teacher once who needed to get exercise
so she would just turn it into a school
thing which is like we have to go
outside for Science and then she would
just like walk around and feel sweating
we're not doing anything for science
it's like we're in a city walking around
the block at least you got to go outside
though that was nice yeah we didn't care
we were like Yay outside and then the
teacher was like trust me it's for
science oh great okay girl we believe
you like I think that's part of it right
our education system is uh not extremely
effective especially these look like
there are a ton of uh young boys young
boys don't benefit well they don't
benefit by sitting at a desk all day
that's not uh the optimal learning
situation for like what are these Middle
School boys I think that we can all
agree it's good to have students get
learning about the news and be engaged
in cultural events but like I think this
is some teacher saying come on let's
organize something I I think it's I
don't know I get frustrated with stuff
like this because it will see this video
and nothing will happen right if there
are really adult men that are being
inserted into the school the fact that
these kids are theoretically upset about
it won't mean anything to the school
board that's kind of hilarious they were
like we got a bunch of adult men who
need to sleep in your school kids it's
like well all right and and here let me
show you this other follow-up videos
this really exemplifies everything very
well listen to this
they're not families who fled war is
what she sang bam way more
fleeing
this woman should right away there
should be like
there should be a group of people who go
there and say ma'am I'm sorry but you
can't vote anymore yes we're just not a
lot we just so this is all right so this
is one massive problem with the
discourse whenever anyone tries to set
any standard no matter how reasonable
they're met with a million different
concerns about the level of culpability
there might be for people who want to
violate that standard so what she's
essentially saying is well why did they
flee why are they here okay it doesn't
matter they shouldn't be at that school
that's it that's it that's it either
explain to me why that's an appropriate
place for them to be and change my mind
or stop engaging with this conversation
don't give me a million and one reasons
why we should feel bad for them we can
feel bad for a lot of people that we
need to have rules as a society for this
woman you don't approach her and argue
with her and let her ask why you're
blocking say why do you want adult men
in the school just Just give me a reason
and then when she goes their family's
fleeing War and be like okay well that
that's not what we're talking about I I
would I'll play this I'll say okay ma'am
if you came to me with a family and said
this this family fleeing War needs a
place I'd be agree with you but my
question too is why do you want adult
men
by themselves looking for jobs sleeping
in my kid's school and also you since
you're so enlightened and empathetic and
understanding why don't you go buy some
hotel rooms for him why don't you take
care of it instead of putting it on the
children of the community by placing
them in their schools I propose I said
you know let's get the Republicans on
this one a bill that says all
you know all these Asylum Seekers you
know if someone comes into this country
and applies for Asylum they should be
placed inside the home of uh an urban
liberal Democrat voter go to New York
and say they applied for Asylum so they
get to live in your house sorry sounds
good you voted for it because you know
what happened these people would vote
for border security in two seconds if we
if we did that the issue is this video
exemplifies how people in Democrat
cities vote to bring in illegal
immigrants and then try and force them
on poor people say not in my backyard in
your backyard no no no we're going to
put them in your backyard from now on
let's get that bill these people go to
cities and they put them in your house
this lady who's like their family's
fleeing War let's get two of these adult
men and put them in our home and it's
not just force them it's then guilt and
shame them if you dare to reject the you
know hypothesis that just dozens of you
know fighting age men should just be
able to basically invade your country
invade your house and I think
immigration is one of the issues that
the elites really really love to lie to
us the most about and I know there are a
lot of issues that could compete for
that spot but I think they just love the
issue of immigration in part because I
think at their core they hate this
country they don't think it actually
there's nothing to actually being
American to that them but the fact that
they have the gall to stand up there
whether it's Democrats holding press
conferences you know on the hill saying
that immigration is actually a boon to
America it's actually great for American
workers they're doing the jobs that
Americans want it's such a lie it's so
ridiculous when it's depressing the
wages of American workers particularly
the people that Democrats purport to
protect the most the minority
communities I just think they they
really get off online to the American
people about immigration and it's one of
the issues honestly that red pilled me I
was born and raised in Los Angeles and I
saw firsthand how hypocritical these
people were when it came to not just
immigration but to every issue it was
fine if it was happening elsewhere you
know somewhere where they weren't
impacted but the second it encroached
um not even necessarily in their
backyard but just a little too close for
comfort uh suddenly they they reversed
at least in private on the issue and
they would do everything they could to
make sure it didn't affect them you I
mean you can very easily predict whether
someone is going to be liberal or
conservative based on whether they're
going to pay the price for Liberal
policies and people who have to pay the
price for Liberal policies inevitably
become conservative and people who do
not have to pay any price for it keep
spouting their little talking points and
then shaming anyone who has to suffer
because of their policies for not
embracing the suffering with absolute
Joy yeah I mean it's crazy as well if
you go to La like and you would know
this as well if you're in Beverly Hills
the Town Police there or like the the
area police keep that little area very
nice and very clean and very tidy you
drive about 10 minutes down the street
and you're on 6th Street and it's
totally different story but remember the
guy who was cheering on on Twitter the
riots and then once the ride started
heading towards Beverly Hills like no
why
Town don't
to go back to the Martha's Vineyard
example they immediately removed them
none of the migrants stayed on Martha
Vineyard they shipped him to Cape Cod
where they sit on a military base they
were willing to get rid of this problem
as soon as it was inconvenient to them
that's why I again I said this before
but I'm gonna go to super chats so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button
running perfect for me there's nothing
nothing because I talked about Cape Cod
they're so touchy on the internet about
that yeah on our end everything is is
totally fine it's it's literally just
lag Spike glitch yeah yep that's YouTube
sorry I was stepping on a cable FBI
let's uh let's uh it's like frame
jumping now we've got we've got no
dropped frames we've got perfect
connection we've got high-speed internet
so just nothing wrong anyway blame
YouTube If this FBF UFO is the thing
that the show running and you guys sat
me near it I'm gonna be real mad because
I don't need this kind of pressure Let's
uh let's read some super chats Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Tim local distributor
stacked of pallid palette beer
everywhere Bud Light and back corner
nearly empty me to clerk dang you
selling lots of Bud Light him nope it's
the only beer we didn't restock
yeah I mean if you can't move it this is
what John rich said when he at first he
was like look we're not moving it we're
not we're not moving Bud Light that's
we're not getting rid of it because the
boy guy says nobody's buying it so what
are we supposed to do we're gonna we're
gonna stock a different beer if nobody
wants it
yep holistic Patriot says we want
official Temple beanies big boxes of
official beans actually I got one right
here whoa whoa hold on I'm a journalist
Now give me a meme there you go Seamus
is going to put on the official Tim
castabini and should I have like the
bush logo facing for this well you can
also it can also be worn like a slouch
Bean if you unfold it oh no way yeah so
you can wear it as however that it's
frozen and then I can see on our back
end everything seems to be fun
all right where are we at Wrath of Paul
says you were talking about bear attacks
yesterday and my first thought was I'd
rather take my chances with the Bears in
the middle of nowhere than live among
humans in some of these big cities
completely agree we do need bear
wrestlers that's what I learned
yesterday as a journalist I believe it
is the case that more people are harmed
by other people than bears that is a
fact
journalist agree that is I've learned
thank you they're consenting yeah the
fact Checkers all agree with me I am
correct
it's it's funny because it's slightly
it's sort of your Tucker Carlson voice
this is how I talk it's a it's your
journalist voice this is my journalist
voice all right Mad Max says Durham
report in six words they all got away
with it watch Greg gutfeld's epic rant
about the Durham report very interesting
all right where are we at on woke says I
like the name of your decaf coffee sure
do wish I thought of it first talk about
seditious conspiracy so we have two
decaf Brands uh or Blends there's a
light and a dark decaf sleepy Joe and
unwoke
that's right and those were the names
came up were thought of by our members
if you want to buy our coffee go to
castbrew.com you can buy them there like
your ass Sheamus can't do it he can't in
person I'm getting close see practice
makes perfect practice makes perfect as
a journalist I will learn but you're but
like you're just talking that's how
you're talking but you're not changing
your voice we sound so similar uh-huh
it's that that Garfield Joe Rogan is
also hard to do an impression of I know
I'm getting I'll I'll nail yours down
eventually like Trump is a little
difficult but he has that nasally you
put your tug over here
over the back of your mouth when you
talk to get that daisley kind of thing
no and then and then you gotta get the
Kadri you go down when you say it
everyone in the chat tell me do I sound
like Tim let me know in the comments
below you don't they'll decide they will
that was more like Tucker Carlson you
don't sound like him but I can
understand what Cadence your
I'm like that's that's what I have so
far we'll work on it I'll keep doing the
same voice and then eventually I'll have
a Tim mcgregation down here's the point
no how could you guys say no eventually
I'll get the impression down and then
when on days where you're sick I'll just
put the beanie on and I'll just pretend
here's my point look Jordan Peterson has
this thing where he's like psychologist
he's got this like way of speaking
exactly to him exactly and then like for
whatever is about me or Joe it's just
generic perhaps like Joe has a unique
voice you know when you hear it but
impersonating it's like how do you you
can't it's tough can't get it well Joe
Rogan's voice is it's it's like I think
you could probably get his Cadence down
but his actual intonation like his voice
I'm sorry you could get his intonation
too but the voice itself is so unique we
gotta send one of these beanies of
Michael malice
because he he did that one episode where
he wore the same clothes as me and then
and then he kept the beanie and he hung
up on his wall right I literally got
asked on Twitter what I like with my
camellos and I said that he's a showman
and he's not afraid of costumes yeah
yeah he also has the I think we gave him
the aluminum foil hat that Alex Jones
made no way I mean those are artifacts
man yeah all right where are we at where
are we at
what do we have on these here super
chats Let's uh let's find a good Super
Chat one day I'll get my impression of
Tim down have you practiced like then
you'll always see that at night sorry
well clearly not if I did it would be a
plus you do what have you been
practicing for years already it's just
that difficult it's a really hard one to
crack but I'll get it
I think let's grab some what do we got
which says they're not conspiracies
they're spoilers uh I've I've heard
people try and do Joe Rogan and they
just they can't get Joe Rogan maybe
that's what the video of trump and the
elevator was it was trouble
perfect
oh my gosh I do want to see that video
then Sheamus as a journalist please find
Trump doing an impression I think it's
my duty as a journalist a journalist
as a journalist Joe Hill says don't
forget Ukraine also interfered in the
2016 election by helping Clinton with
steel dossier uh Ukraine I think it was
um manafort documents wasn't it yeah
they they really I thought it was
manafort but yeah yeah and then even
Politico said that they were scrambling
after interfering to uh to help the
clintons
and then Politico wrote another article
later claiming that their their article
was disinformation from Russia
yeah it's just hilarious Politico is
Russian disinformation says Politico but
they told you themselves so you can't be
mad at them
Joshua says once again Sheamus is
rolling twenties he's literally The
Reincarnation of Midas at this point
because everything about him is pure
gold even the potatoes you are so kind
thank you except my Tim impression but I
do appreciate the compliment that's very
kind Amish man says incredible guest I
was a huge fan of yours growing up
watching you on Boy Meets World please
tell Ben Savage to come on Tim castiron
next do you hear that a lot I get that a
lot and I actually didn't know who she
was at first I don't know her name I
know the character is Topanga but I
don't know the actress's name
like they were stoned when they were
writing that show they were like it's
like a show about a kid in school and
you know his name is what was his name
in the show are you right I I think it
was but there's also uh Corey is a good
name and then you got like John Mike
Bill and Topanga and they're like and
her explanation is like I've never
really seen the show but it's like her
parents are hippies and let's not talk
about it again well they're still paying
a canyon yeah they're saying like she's
named after like right above Malibu yeah
but the thing is like some TV shows
names that are in them because become
popular sort of trend as baby names but
I don't think anybody picked up on the
Topanga Trend it's kind of a cool name
is this what you're gonna name your
daughter baby oh my future Topanga
two on the nose no people always say
that and I I never do you watch the show
no oh no I I honestly growing up I never
really watched movies or TV so I never
understand it's kind of pop culture like
I was on war room once on an episode and
Steve turned to me he was asking me how
I do a lot of my reporting and I said
well primarily pattern recognition and
he goes you're just like rain man you're
like the guy and I I didn't know what he
meant by that so I was like thank you
and then I later looked it up I was like
oh I think you just called me like
autistic amazing
Rain Man was really good at playing
Blackjack yeah he's gonna get a math so
yeah take me to a casino but I hadn't
seen rain man I only saw it passively
when I was a kid but I know the Trope is
like they go to Vegas and they play
Blackjack so I was like I really want to
watch this movie and it's barely about
that it's literally just a story about a
guy who comes to love his brother he had
just met for the first time and I was
like oh yeah I thought it was like a
sweet film it is I thought it was going
to be about like
I thought the movie was literally a guy
takes his brother to Vegas to win a
bunch of money and get super rich when
it was really a guy finds out he has a
brother at one point goes to Vegas one
time gets kicked out but then decides
that he loves his brother even though
his brother is developmentally disabled
and then tries to fight for custody but
then eventually just ends up visiting
him periodically and I'm like oh it's
that's not at all what I thought the
movie was I read the Wikipedia summary
yeah and thought it's not at all but I
gathered from that I thought it was just
about gambling
that's the part people remember like
right sorry go ahead is there a movie
about like some guy at MIT who's like
been part of a secret poker yeah and
they're counting cards well this happens
though where you'll remember a movie
being about something and you remember
that being the whole movie and it turns
out that's just like a 10 or 15 minute
sequence right like I remember I
rewatched home alone a couple years ago
and the the sequence where he's like
beating up on the burglars with his
booby traps I think it's like 10 to 20
minutes it's really most of the film is
just about him like running around being
stupid while parents are gone and when
he's in New York you know he just meets
Donald Trump that's a whole movie it's
just two hours literally just the same
movie twice it's the exact same movie
twice like every plot Point
understood sequels right they're like
this format worked children loved it
we'll plug in slightly different
variables we'll do it again
in New York you know sure where who else
would be after exactly we don't want to
create too many bad guys we don't freak
children out that's true there aren't
that many bad people in the world Sean
Austin says Tim deep fake Trump in an
elevator picking his nose and release it
as the elevator tape ultimate troll I
saw that so I went on Mid journey and I
just made Trump screaming and then Trump
crying and then it's Trump holding his
neck going like ah in an elevator and I
just quote tweeted the having to post
thing like there it is there's your
there's your I found it best journalist
ever that's right I tried a couple I
tried a couple and I couldn't get it to
work because they violated the TLs I I
wrote like Trump firing a gun into the
air yelling and it wouldn't make it and
well every time every time I tried to
make Joe Biden or Trump uh it would say
rejected and I'd have to click appeal
and then it would say your appeal has
been approved and it would make the
image and then the weirdest thing is I
tried doing some very basic images what
I was trying to do was take a picture an
existing picture and then write
something like a woman standing in this
picture and then it would be like
rejected this is inappropriate con and I
was like what uh you know what I think
was happening
so mid-journey is trained on the
internet and I think the issue is the
The Prompt discovered like my prompt was
innocuous a woman standing in a forest
and I was like here's and then you can
upload the picture and then it'll render
it
I think mid-journey was trying to make
sexual images because of what the
internet is when you search for women
maybe like sports bras or like women in
bikinis and stuff like that so the AI
was like nope this is making something
naughty we can't show it to you and I
was just like hey wait a minute like I
did not ask for anything bad I'm trying
to just see what mid-journey can do here
so a bunch of the stuff I tried doing I
would put like uh here's the trick you
put high-res photograph the caption
Getty Images and then what that'll do is
it'll imitate a Getty image which is
typically like news footage of an event
and that's how I made Donald Trump
running with Sonic the Hedgehog and it
looks actually like Trump is running
Sonic looks totally fake because of
course Sonic's not a real thing but
Trump looks like he's actually running
and then I wrote America's back so uh
that's those are some of the tricks
you'll also notice if you go into the
mid-journey rooms and Discord there's
this huge wall of text people used that
lists a whole bunch of camera and file
formats to force the AI to make high
resolution High dynamic range
photographs that look really really good
wow yeah it's it's crazy what they can
make when you when you put in that
massive prompt it's cool stuff
yeah
Cain Abel says Sheamus if you want to be
a journalist to just copy the mainstream
by making bull crap up that is pretty
much all they do now you can just add a
Twist to it to make it funny I'm excited
to start doing that yeah so like let's
let's do this you don't want to get sued
so uh Sheamus put on this beanie right
well as we know new zealots have claimed
Tim pool is far right uh we can now
write Sheamus Coughlin Don's offensive
far-right costume on air considered
deeply offensive by by many shocking
display etc etc and then you know people
can start to imagine after you tweet
that out I am shocked by Sheamus
Coughlin donning such a racist and
far-right costume that's deeply
offensive to marginalized people someone
else can then say summarizing Sheamus
Coughlin was accused of wearing racist
outfit so you can keep changing the
story this is what they do and then it's
me dressed as a leprechaun but it's all
it's it's all uh you can't sue over it
because it's it it's it this is this is
what's happening to our society it's the
bank robbery analogy I used a guy walks
up to a bank and throws a burlap sack on
the steps and keeps walking that's not
illegal another guy walks in picks up
the burlap sack and throws it in the
lobby carries out his business another
guy brings the burlap sec to the counter
and says I think someone dropped this
and then leaves another guy throws a
note a demand note onto the steps
someone brings it in not no one knows
who wrote it or where it came from the
guy who picked it up on the ground
didn't do it and then all of these
people did one little thing so when the
money is removed from the bank and then
thrown into a truck not a single person
robbed the bank no one goes to jail this
is what's happening right now in society
journalists will say something like I
heard Sheamus was racist and then
someone will write Sheamus accused of of
being racist then another journalist
will write Shameless Shameless Sheamus
comma a deeply racist individual or a
man accused of being deeply racist comma
and then someone else will see that and
be like Sheamus Coughlin is known as a
deeply offensive racist who makes racist
comments they'll just keep changing the
story until they make up and fabricate
their own sources and then they can
write whatever they want
they can be like Sheamus you're a
controversial figure who's been accused
of being a racist what do you say to
that you're like when by who and then
it's this huge chain of fake news
written by the same people we have this
Source this Source this Source this
Source
it's several Google page results deep
that they they have this but there's no
supporting evidence
all right kgs KJ seed says Tim I have
grown a towards vivek's message do you
think his campaign is real or is it for
Book Sales I think it's real
um I think a reasonable person can
conclude that Vivek probably won't win
but a lot of people run for messaging
purposes I'm not gonna uh tell you I
think Vivek really does want to win I
genuinely think so I would I would argue
that he probably knows he wouldn't but
I'm not going to say that because I
don't know what he's thinking I would
just I think he's a smart guy he knows
his likelihood of winning is very low
very low I would imagine his intent is
to force a message on ESG onto the
debate stage and to push this into
modern politics
however I think he's trying to win and
he wants to win you know I think even
Trump was surprised that he won what was
the story like on Election night when
the results came in he was like did we
win like did that really happen like wow
like he didn't think it was going to
happen
but uh I think vivek's great I think
it's great
what do we got here
absinthex says Sheamus Catholic church
has commands as don't covet your
neighbor's wife and things but Exodus
only says don't covet anything so which
commandment was removed so the count
still comes out as ten wait hold on
you're saying Exodus says so Exodus does
list a number of things you can't covet
there uh but if you actually read Exodus
20 it's a number of different statements
so Jewish people and Protestants number
it a little bit differently than
Catholics
so for example at the end we break up
the the ninth and tenth commandment into
the Thou shalt not covet your neighbor's
Goods or covet your neighbor's wife and
I'm sorry covering coveting your
neighbor's wife is the ninth commandment
coveting your neighbor's good is the
tenth commandment but yeah there are
other things listed I guess I'm not
entirely sure what he's asking like what
was
I don't know if I understand either yeah
yeah could you reread that
uh he's basically saying that
I I honestly I don't know some some say
don't cover anything some say don't
covet your neighbor's wife and things oh
okay so so here's there are a number of
differences right so for example if you
if you and I have this pulled up here
but uh you shall not make for yourself
an image in the form of anything in
Heaven above or on Earth beneath or in
the waters below you shall not bow down
before them or worship them for I Am
Lord your God I am a jealous God
punishing the children for the sins of
the parents to the third and fourth
generation of those who hate me but
showing love to a thousand generations
of love for those who love me and keep
my Commandments okay so yeah that's
that's compressed Into You shall not
make graven images the way Protestants
some of the Ten Commandments as
Catholics we lump
uh taking other gods before him as uh
something that also prohibits making
graven images and then worshiping them
so there are there are different ways
that these things are numbered but and
so I but that's not something that
people don't acknowledge like that's not
a secret I guess is my point we should
we should do an episode of the culture
war with you and Ian because you guys
were supposed to do that long-form
conversation that never happened so we
should yeah we should we should get
together on that one all right Noah
Sanders says where is the timcast
fact-checking non-profit company we are
all still waiting to have fact Checkers
we can trust keep it the great and hard
work
um in the process of filing so uh I
think it takes like years
yeah the problem is typically like a
non-profit will start in a state get
their Federal number and then file in
the state to do everything
these systems were created back before
the internet so typically if you start a
non-profit it was just in one state and
you filed and then you'd operate now we
have to file in every single state
because our audience exists all over the
country which brings up another issue a
lot of people are asking you know their
members and they were asked to update
their their address or information it's
because we have reached a threshold now
where we have members in every different
state and territory so we have to
collect that information for tax
purposes it's a legal requirement and
then we have to pay those taxes so
that's that's reality as for the fact
checking nonprofit we've got some
prominent individuals who have said
they're committed on donating to to help
fund this operation we're really excited
for it
um we probably need to get out
uh the the challenge for us is
managerial because of how many different
states and how many different
regulations there are
but I think we might be able to hire
somebody
and then get some uh revenue from a
single state where we filed so far and
then use that to kick start the process
so it just it is what it is we're
working on it you know
Ben Keith says the judge for tomorrow's
carry Lake trial gutted carries case in
a ruling today now Kerry's lawyer cannot
question if the signature verification
process was fraudulent only if a check
took place for questionable ballots
so
I I think based on what I read
Carrie Lake still has a decent case if
she can show that signatures don't match
you can make the argument that the
process did not take place right so
Katie Hobbs I went over this this is
really funny so uh Katie Hobbs has a a
guide as Secretary of State this is from
2020 on how to verify signatures and
what makes something questionable I
pulled up the New York Times where it's
like here's 11 signatures which ones
match and then based on Katie Hobbs
signature verification guidelines I
successfully chose the two signatures
that matched out of 11. I was actually
surprised I was able to pull that off I
thought I was gonna get it wrong but I
got it right based on that information
if Kerry Lake says here are here's a
handful of ballots that do not adhere to
Katie hobbs's guidelines she could argue
this shows they did not signature verify
you could make they might argue no it
just means the verification was poorly
done I think well hold on if the if the
guideline says if it does this this or
this it's not verified and these two
these things don't adhere to the
guideline you can argue they didn't
verify it I thought it was poorly done
they just didn't even do it I think
that's what she's gonna have to argue
but I've not seen the evidence we've got
to see her present the evidence we'll
see
she posted photos of 2020 ballots right
let's see what they got
let's grab some more Super chats
the TJ drummer says Bud Light launching
this campaign so close to Memorial Day
two rolling a huge one guys oof
yep
Kevin cost uh cosnahan says heineken's
cheers to all the fans commercial seems
to have taken shots at Bud Light at the
end of the commercial oh I haven't seen
that one
I gotta check that one out let's uh let
me write that one down Heineken
commercial
I'll check that one out when we uh when
we rap
what do we got llama says hey Tim for
those of us who don't drink coffee maybe
you could start a line of teas a fun
Roberto in style inspired line of tease
maybe something like tease it's
very very clever uh we are currently
working on forecaster.com supplements
but like protein powder and MCT so
probably we're never going to do any
kind of vitamins or weird Brain Blast
stuff I don't I'm not into that stuff
but what I am into when exercising is
like a protein powder and MCT powder
we're big fans of that stuff so we're
thinking of uh creating our own Blends
and launching our own we're we're
looking at what we can uh what we can do
in terms of proprietary Blends and mixes
and the regulations and all that stuff
but we think we might actually be able
to launch that very very soon very
excited for that and then um for Roberto
inspired lines of tease we're talking
about Roberto Jr
now as for Roberto the original King
maybe we'll make a uh you know a medium
roast called like Return of the King
Roberto you know I like them yeah Return
of the King
but also Roberto Jr is getting close to
retirement
that's right who's his successor uh I
don't know we don't know we don't know
yet
um so they have to audition what's the
like how does it work out no clue but we
don't want Roberto Jr knocking so we're
incubating a whole bunch of Roberto Jr
babies right now I think like 30
something he's a rooster and so we're
gonna have gonna say who is this yeah
we're gonna have a whole bunch of uh
not from our world
that's these people
die after he has the babies we don't
want just like with Roberto Roberto
banged his daughter and because chickens
do okay I'm glad you established that
we're talking about chickens because if
I thought we were talking about humans
and you said that I would have been good
he's a complicated character roosters do
this chicken chickens do this
um you can only do it so much and so we
remove Roberto and bring in his son
which still does have Roberto genetics
in there which is kind of needs to start
a farm I don't know if we have the space
in DC but I'm very impressed are you
jealous of the chicken Empire I I really
am I we don't have anything yeah we're
gonna have like 70 chickens oh and also
the uh they they had babies the silkies
had four babies and the coaching had two
they've just decided to take them take
it upon themselves to make more of
themselves and uh they decided they are
reclaiming the family
uh they're inspired it is it is the
radical Pro family dude it's literally I
gotta tell you it is horrifyingly
magical to see the chicken with like the
little chickens underneath it and then
you open the thing and it looks at you
and it goes like I like if you come near
my babies it's a chicken selection but
you can lift up the mom and she looks
around and you can see the little babies
going like and then she tries to keep
them warm and stuff it's very it's very
cute and when it's like raining the
chick Mom will like cover the babies to
keep them dry and
yeah it's great when they when they have
their own babies because they'll protect
them whereas if you incubate them you
have to protect them because chickens
don't care they're like I ain't my baby
no
let's grab uh we'll grab one more Super
Chat here what do we got and the old uh
Super Chat has YouTube YouTube's
breaking down
so I finally broke YouTube Hooray
Clayton Webb says ordered coffee on
April 22nd haven't shipped any ideas
when to expect it should be soon so
um we we we sold way too much way too
quickly and it overloaded so I apologize
nice humble break Tim if it hasn't has
hasn't come out we didn't expect it I
mean we I think we had uh several
thousand of each available and then it
all just sold basically instantly and
we're like oh man we had to like rush
and try and sell more and then I had to
put in a bunch of personal money to try
and cover the costs so so it is making
money but it's it's selling too quickly
so we can't keep up with orders we're
hoping to that point of equilibrium and
then uh it'll stabilize but uh yeah so
thank you for buying cast brew coffee
and uh the coffee shop is currently
underway with a lot of work being done
and it's taken a long time because
inspections Plumbing just a whole bunch
of crazy stuff to get it up and running
but it's coming so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends become a
member at timcast.com that members only
show will be up in about 10 minutes on
the front page of timcast.com you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast Natalie
do you want to shout anything out I'm
Natalie G Winters on Twitter and all the
social media platforms and of course
tune in to war room 10 to 12 and 5 to 7.
um my name is Seamus Coughlin I'm a
journalist I am also a political
cartoonist and satirist I run a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes if you guys
want to support that channel and what I
do then go over to freedomtunes.com and
become a member you will get an extra
cartoon each week that only members get
we're also going to be uploading more
stuff like behind the scenes podcasts
there are perks like being entered in
Raffles to be a background character in
videos so please head over there check
that out thank you very much
I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should 110 follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's great if you want to follow me
personally you can follow me on
Instagram at hannahclare.b and on
Twitter at HC brimlow thank you so much
and I am surge.com sorry about the audio
uh it's not me so yeah uh follow me at
twitter.com I had a lot of fun uh
arguing with you guys yesterday it's
always great I love it
we will see you all over at timcast.com
for that uncensored members only show in
a few minutes thanks for hanging out